[Musik]
wir menschen als spezies wann immer tief
mit dem land verbunden dass uns ernährt
heutzutage gibt es kaum noch leute die
wissen wo das essen herkommt das auf
ihren tischen landet
[Musik]
dabei ist es so unglaublich schönen mehr
zeit draußen zu verbringen mit den
händen in der erde zu fühlen zeit mit
den tieren zu verbringen und zumindest
einen kleinen teil von dem was man isst
selber anzubauen
das erdet ein es gibt einen inneren
frieden viele leute heutzutage gar nicht
mehr kennt
[Musik]
unser alltag ist oft so hektisch und so
schnelllebig dass es wahnsinnig gut tut
einfach mal den pausen button zu drücken
und zu sagen das kann warten ich
verbringe diesen wunderschönen tag heute
unter freiem himmel und schafft was mit
meinen eigenen händen
[Musik]
und manchmal auch noch mal solche
kartoffeln wir können backups machen und
screenshots und eine firewall
installieren zumindest manche
aber wer kann heutzutage noch sein
eigenes feuer machen
wir hatten schon zehnjährige kinder zu
gesucht die nicht wissen dass kartoffeln
unter der erde wachsen
ganz ehrlich wie sollen wir von dieser
generation auch nur im geringsten
erwarten dass sie sich um den schutz
dieses unglaublichen planeten kümmert
wenn sie gar keinen bezug mehr dazu hat
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
viele leute sagen immer ich hätte so
lust einen eigenen garten anzulegen und
wenigstens ein bisschen was selber
anzubauen männer hinterm haus zu halten
aber hinterm haus ist kein garten ist es
überhaupt möglich in der stadt eine
nennenswerte menge an nahrung selber zu
produzieren
und da kann ich nur sagen ja absolut ja
das ist so was von möglich
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben auch
nur einen quadratmeter eigenes land
besessen und auch jetzt wurden wir in
einer wohnung mitten in der stadt ohne
eigenen garten und ich kann trotzdem
genug obst und gemüse für zwei
erwachsene und ein kind selber anbauen
wirklich
[Musik]
wir müssen auch keine eier und kein
fleisch mehr zu kaufen und normalerweise
bekommen wir unsere milchprodukte von
unserer kleinen ziegenherde dieses jahr
das leider nicht geklappt unsere milch
ziege im winter leider gestorben ist
aber ab nächstem jahr steht das dann
auch wieder auf dem programm
[Musik]
wenn ein
der gemüsegarten ist ungefähr 300
quadratmeter groß personen wie die reine
mietfläche und der ist aufgeteilt auf
zwei grundstücke einmal hier den
küchengarten da bei euch alles an muss
man zum frischverzehr braucht und wo man
regelmäßig erntet und dann habe ich noch
weiter weg einen acker wachsen zum
beispiel die kartoffeln und die kürbisse
die lager möhren und rote beete also
alles was ein bisschen weniger
aufmerksamkeit braucht aber nicht die
gemüse die jetzt regelmäßig zum kochen
brauche wenn ich für spritzen auf den
tisch zaubern möchte wir wachsen alle
hier im kirchengarten weil das einfach
ein bisschen näher dran ist
ich brauche ungefähr drei stunden in der
woche im durchschnitt also im frühling
und sommer sind es auch mal mehr im
winter deutlich weniger um unseren
gemüsegarten zu bewirtschaften und das
ist wirklich wirklich machbar
[Musik]
viele leute glauben im auge hat das
könnte ich nie im winter nur karotten
und eingelagerte sachen essen hessens
bauen wir im winter auch super viele
unterschiedliche gemüse an zb im
gewächshaus kann man immer noch jede
menge tolle gemüse anbauen aber auch
tausenden und zweitens versuchen wir im
sommer so viel wie möglich von der
sommerernte haltbar zu machen
und das ist ein wahnsinnig tolles gefühl
wenn man im winter vor seinem
vorratsschrank schritt und man hat einen
heißen boden den kriegs frei auf dem
herd und dann holt man sich so ein
jahrzehnt blauem aus dem schrank und
tisch die der eigenen familie auf es
macht einfach stolz den sommer zurück zu
holen die man irgendwie geschafft hat in
diesem kleinen glas einzufangen
[Musik]
hier gibt es auch eine wahnsinnige
wertschätzung für die lebensmittel die
bei uns auf dem tisch landen wenn ich
weiß ich habe jetzt ein halbes jahr oder
länger keine frischen tomaten gegessen
und da hängen welche an der pflanze die
sind gerade noch grün aber vielleicht
kann ich in zwei wochen die ersten essen
[Musik]
natürlich können wir uns nicht zu 100
prozent selbst versorgen und das ist
auch gar nicht das ziel von diesem
projekt überhaupt nicht zb kaufen wir
immer noch das getreide ein dass wir zum
brotbacken brauchen oder zum kochen wir
können auch keine selber herstellen
theoretisch wäre das möglich aber dass
wir so viel arbeit dass ich da ehrlich
gesagt gar keine lust drauf hätte und
schokolade wächst auch nicht auf bäumen
zumindest nicht hier also wir müssen
immer noch jede menge sachen im laden
kaufen und ich finde das auch überhaupt
nicht schlimm das wäre nie mein anspruch
irgendwie komplett unabhängig von der
gesellschaft zu sein damit irgendwie
einzuigeln unsere mieten dasein zu
fristen
[Musik]
ich finde es super schön in den
bereichen wo es spaß macht und wo es
leicht ist so viel wie möglich selber zu
machen
aber ansonsten freue ich nicht genauso
wenig zum bauern hier in der gegend
gehen kann und mir da mein dinkel oder
meinen buchweizen kaufen und ihnen damit
unterstütze und so
selbstversorgung auch auf regionaler
ebene betrachtet
[Musik]
pink ist die leidenschaft für gärtnern
und will selbstversorgung schon immer in
mir gewesen ich weiß noch dass ich als
kind mein gesamtes taschengeld auf ein
buch über selbstversorgung gespielt habe
und das habe ich habe das absolut
geliebt dieses buch hat das in und
auswendig gekonnt das war meine bibel
[Musik]
ich wollte unbedingt an als ich ein kind
war meinen eigenen kleinen bauernhof
haben ich habe mir nichts sehnlicher
gewünscht als meine eigenen siegen und
mit zwölf habe ich die dann auch
geschenkt bekommen von meinen eltern wie
sind die besten seitdem habe ich ziehe
jetzt seit 15 jahren
und die haben sich dann auch ziemlich
schnell vermehrt so dass ich zeit weil
sie mitten in der stadt mitten in kassel
also einer kleinen großstadt aber schon
mal richtig östlichen stadt hatte ich 20
10 ohne ein eigenes grundstück zu haben
wir haben dafür immer die augen offen
gehalten nach grundstücken diese
aussehen und sich niemand darum kümmert
und dann herausgefunden wie im die
gehören nachgefragt angeboten dass wir
die grundstücke pflegen können oder ob
wir die im gegenzug nutzen können und
das hat bisher super funktioniert und
die leute sind oft auch total dankbar
wenn sich jemand um das dünnste kümmert
um sie keine verwendung für haben
ich glaube in größeren städten ist das
ein bisschen schwieriger aber nicht
unmöglich ich habe auch in freiburg
gewohnt fünf jahre lang und da musste
ich eben ein bisschen weiter raus aufs
land fahren bis ich meine ziegen dann
hatte aber das hat trotzdem immer
funktioniert wie dich glaubt wo ein
wille ist das auf jeden fall auch ein
[Musik]